there should be no such thing as student
debt this far right corrupt Supreme
Court and with this unjust decision is
it unjust to make people pay
back court just struck there's no binds
loan for getting his plan ruling 6-3
that the plan was an unconstitutional
overreach of executive spending power
and man was Biden trying to spend the
truth is canceling student debt would be
expensive but counterproductive and do
absolutely nothing to reduce the cost of
going to college by some estimates the
plan would have cost over 400 billion
dollars most of which would have gone to
helping wealthy Americans without
actually decreasing student debt in the
long term the plan also screws over
those who made sacrifices to pay off
their debt or avoid it all together as
well as a generation of students about
to enter College who won't see the
benefits of debt forgiveness instead we
should focus on policies that attack the
root of the issue doing anything else is
the real unjustice